carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
reciban un cordial saludo desde parís
muy agradecida de que quieran pasar este
momento en nuestra compañía como siempre
les ofrecemos un paseo por las noticias
del mundo del arte y de la cultura en
francia
carrusel de las artes los lleva a
descubrir un lugar único cargado de
espiritualidad el valle de los santos en
el corazón de bretaña un proyecto en
homenaje a los santos fundadores de la
región
nuestras cámaras fueron al teatro
mogador de parís donde se presenta la
más reciente versión del musical el rey
león que rinde tributo a la diversidad y
cultura africanas en los estrenos del
cine francés una película basada en
hechos reales y un melodrama sobre un
amor imposible y en nuestra crónica
musical conoceremos al cantante action h
y su aventura sinfónica para celebrar
los 50 años de la mítica emisora de
radio feedback
[Música]
comenzamos con nuestro programa en
bretaña al oeste de francia una región
conocida por sus méritos y venires allí
ha surgido el valle de los santos un
vasto espacio poblado de esculturas de
gran formato dedicadas a los santos del
folklore bretón vamos allá de la mano de
melissa barra
[Música]
ciento cincuenta y cinco gigantes de
granito son los guardianes de este valle
ubicado en camp nou en el corazón de
bretaña hace más de una década nació
este proyecto de esculturas monumentales
con la intención de alcanzar los 1000
monolitos y así representar la multitud
de santos que forman parte de la cultura
popular bretona
la bota y el peine sa bretaña es la
región de francia con mayor tradición de
santos cuando vemos un mapa nos damos
cuenta que cada municipio lleva el
nombre de un santo como sample desde un
mall o santi connect
este proyecto es una forma de recordar
la historia de bretaña y su fundación en
el medioevo esa cultura popular
corresponde a los relatos de la vida de
los santos que contaban las veladas
frente a las chimeneas en las vigilias
en nuestra mitología bretona en otro
mito noche y botón
[Música]
según la leyenda esta región francesa
fue fundada por siete santos fueron los
primeros que se tallaron en este valle
cada escultura mide entre cuatro y siete
metros decenas de artistas del mundo
entero han trabajado en el valle de los
santos tienen 30 días para crear in situ
un santo de granito gris beige azul
rosado el color del santo lo define la
procedencia del bloque de piedra
y matera aquí lo que me interesa es un
vínculo con lo eterno todas las
esculturas que ven pueden llegar a durar
cinco mil años
y el granito tiene una textura con mucha
intensidad se siente que proviene de la
profundidad de la corteza terrestre
con este santo san joan de estudio era
saurí y además de buscar agua atraía la
lluvia
lo de todo el agua que cae sobre la
escultura se recoge en un frasquito en
él se puede leer we can you a no haber o
sea verdadera agua del cielo es potable
y a lo mejor es agua bendita
desde su creación el valle de los santos
ha atraído a dos millones de personas
que lo han visitado por motivos
religiosos espirituales o turísticos
algunos lo apodan la isla de pascua
bretona
[Música]
regresamos ahora a la capital francesa
para llevarlos a uno de los musicales
más exitosos de todos los tiempos el rey
león' volvió al teatro mogador de parís
en una nueva versión de este cuento
lleno de música humanismo y la
diversidad del continente africano
[Música]
doñana
el grito de la sabana africana su
diversidad animal y sus cantos
regresaron con ímpetu a parís el rey
león musical que ha conquistado a 100
millones de espectadores en los últimos
25 años regresó al teatro mogador en una
versión renovada un espectáculo
fascinante para el público y exigente
para los artistas
[Música]
y este en fa con el rey león es un
musical de broadway hay que cantar
bailar actuar pero además de todo eso
tenemos que ser los verdaderos atletas
porque lo más difícil no es cantar el
espectáculo sino cantar lo ocho veces
por semana en el rey león' se hablan
siete lenguas extender su luz lo ágil y
otras es un espectáculo con mucho
respeto de las culturas africanas estoy
muy orgulloso de formar parte de este
elenco en un momento donde justamente el
respeto el multiculturalismo el vivir
juntos y en paz han estado tan
cuestionados entre los artistas hay
orígenes diferentes colores de piel
distintos es una alegría muy grande
[Música]
al igual que la película de dibujos
animados la versión teatral del rey
león' rescata los cantos tradicionales
sudafricanos pero utiliza 300 máscaras
de animales y 400 marionetas y vestidos
para representar a los diferentes
personajes del cuento
[Música]
y si hace clic de petición no es sólo
una reproducción en el escenario de la
película de dibujos animados es mucho
más que eso cada marioneta cada máscara
que llevamos los actores está hecha con
mucha precisión y sin borrar la
presencia humana los creadores del
espectáculo querían evocar el mundo
animal pero que se vieran a los artistas
y sus expresiones es un espectáculo
humanista hasta en ese aspecto que puede
ser un detalle pero que era importante
en este relato ahí nos damos cuenta de
que el rey león' es una historia muy
profunda habla de una búsqueda
existencial en la que cada quien puede
verse reflejado y ahí radica su éxito
[Música]
el rey león el musical se presenta en el
teatro jugador de parís hasta julio de
[Música]
damos una mirada ahora a la cartelera
del cine francés en la que destacamos
los dramas que exploran al ser humano
en el
bombo se estrena en las salas francesas
la película after humboldt el
multipremiado director log on conte la
cinta explora la personalidad doble de
karim de un joven escritor en la cúspide
de su carrera todo se desploma cuando se
descubre el alter ego de karime en redes
sociales un activo polemista con un
discurso racista antisemita homófobo y
misógino que escribe bajo seudónimo
comienza entonces un largo descenso a
los infiernos que lo enfrentará a su
familia amigos y a toda la sociedad
esta cinta está basada en la verdadera
historia de mes ti mezclar un prometedor
escritor y periodista con un discurso
despiadado en redes action combo es una
reflexión sobre la identidad y el poder
que otorga en las redes sociales
[Música]
yo siempre segundo
llega también a las pantallas grandes
una historia de amor imposible lección
samu los jóvenes amantes dirigida por
que aventar dio y basada en una idea de
la desaparecida solbes ansv h
[Música]
en este melodrama relata la pasión que
une a shawn a una mujer de 70 años que
piensa haber pasado la página de su vida
sentimental y de pierre un médico de 45
años casado y padre de familia
una pareja atípica que deberá enfrentar
la mirada del resto de la sociedad
esas imagina piel
[Música]
y llegó la hora de la música a cargo
como siempre de nuestra buscadora de
talentos natale olivares hola natalia
hola maría carolina bueno y hoy vamos a
descubrir gracias a ti natalia a un gran
mereció de la canción francesa que
además es un artista multifacético
porque también es poeta pianista e
ilustrador exactamente manera carolina y
más que un artista completo con una
larga trayectoria ha inspirado a muchos
otros artistas él nos invitó a la casa
de la radio y de la música para su
concierto actor gas pop software nick su
obra pop más la orquesta filarmónica de
radio fans
eso
[Música]
los cast san fermín yo pienso que lo que
más desprende fuerza musical es una vez
que estás sinfónicas fuerza y también
ternura porque puede ser tan potente
como soja y hemos hecho una adaptación
de mis canciones para una orquesta
sinfónica con cuerdas y con todos sus
colores sus espacios espacios
[Música]
y este concierto fue organizado para los
50 años de una radioemisora mítica que
es fib y le rinde homenaje
y una radio muy original que difunde
realmente todos los estilos de música lo
cual es muy poco común pasan canciones
música clásica jazz rap este concierto
es para festejar lo que representa esta
radioemisora que se llama fit
y
[Música]
si se sabe
como me reveló su suave
y ésta fue la ocasión también de hablar
de su último álbum que lleva el sencillo
nombre mohamed de dos pupilas en la fosa
don alfonso de las que en español sería
más o menos muerte prematura de un
cantante populares en la flor de la edad
si no me equivoco algo muy sencillo
un álbum que es una cosa una adaptación
de una obra teatral y nos habló de todo
esto
de la muerte prematura de un cantante
popular en la edad fuerte es una
adaptación de una obra de teatro sobre
la violencia contemporánea sobre cómo
expresar su vida su consternación el
lector ya de un cantante que vive el fin
de su éxito y que pone en escena su
propia muerte porque considera que sólo
cuando un artista muere se le reconoce
su obra evidentemente todo esto es un
fracaso es una obra contemporánea cómica
y trágica en la cual yo participe
tocando así que me inspiré en esta obra
para mi disco
r
[Música]
y muerte prematura de grandes han
existido pienso en este ambiente
sinfónico moussa sow para llover y
tantos otros maría carolina gracias
natale olivares por presentarnos este
actuar versión sinfónica y justamente
para conocer un poco más de su música
vamos a terminar con su tema a valonia
agradeciéndoles por su amable sintonía y
los esperamos la próxima semana bagua
por a
sí
a sólo 2
[Música]